the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I wanted to do a quick review of all the
photon interactions because I've
released problem set five for you guys
it involves your banana data so we're
gonna be taking a second look at all the
banana data and the problem statement
for the lab part is simple identify all
the peaks tell me where they came from
and tell me all the peaks that should be
there that you don't see and why and
that's like a quarter of the problem set
or something so just to review the three
effects that we talked about sort of in
order of what energies they're important
in like my spelling I'm sure will be
slower than usual today
spent yeah totally spent like three and
a half days listening to Russian
presentations with an English translator
microphone Russian England I'm sorry
Russian scientific presentation is
really similar to English all the
technical words are the same but as soon
as you start trying to talk to a
two-year-old you're just lost but it's
pretty cool doing over the photoelectric
effect Compton scattering and pear
production and so in addition to knowing
what these three mechanisms actually are
and how to tell what they would look
like on a given detector spectrum the
other two important things we wanted to
remember are one of the cross sections
so what are the relative probabilities
of each happening as a function of their
energy of the photon and the material
that they're going in and then filling
in this map of if you have energy and Z
where are these effects most prevalent
so as anyone want to kick me off does
anyone remember the general form of the
cross sections for any of these effects
or does anyone remember what this map
looks like yeah Chris
indeed that's right
so pair production think we gave it the
symbol Kappa to go along with the
reading that you guys have was around
here that's because it's not going to
happen below 1.0 to 2 MeV because you
need the energy to make the positron
electron pair and indeed the more
electrons there are in each atom the
more likely pair production is because
this happens when the photon gets near
the nucleus which is going to have a
higher charge for higher Z and so on and
so a pair production it was proportional
to you don't need to know that you'll
never need to know the exact things that
the cross-sections that's what books are
for but it was proportional to let's see
I think it was like Z to the 3rd or 4th
pretty strong like that
what about Compton scattering where does
that lie on this map yup Heisey
low-energy so in this general region
we'll just give it a key for Compton
scattering and in that one the
cross-section was proportional to
something like 1 over the energy or
h-bar Omega in your reading that's the
same thing as saying photon energy and
then what about photoelectric effect
well that's the only place there is left
right we'll give it the symbol tau so
I'll put these up here they don't quite
know why they chose those symbols but
I'll just stick to the notation in the
reading and then the idea here is this
was proportional to something like Z to
the fifth over what is it energy to the
like seven halves so significantly low
energy significantly high Z and does
anyone remember at what energy does the
photoelectric effects start to kick in
very close to zero so here the energy
has got to be greater than or equal to
well what is the photoelectric effect
physically mm-hmm yep a gamma gets
absorbed or any photon gets absorbed and
knocks out an electron so how energetic
is I have to be to knock out the
electron yeah
the binding energy of the lowest bound
electron which we give that symbol fee
or the work function the idea here is
that as soon as you have enough energy
to eject the outermost electron which is
super low for the alkali metals like
sodium potassium cesium then you can
exceed the work function and get the
photoelectric effect going and for this
one we said the energy here has to be
greater than or equal to two times the
rest mass of the electron C squared
better known as 1.0 to 2 MeV is there a
minimum energy for Compton scattering
photons can scatter they don't have to
have any energy to scatter certainly and
let's see the two interesting bits of
technology we talked about related to
these one was called a Compton camera or
you could actually use two detectors
let's say you're looking for a tiny
source in a big box somewhere
you can have one detector and you can
have a second detector so that this
source is sending out gammas in all
directions and let's say one of them
interacts with detector one bounces off
and interacts in detector 2 at that
point you've constrained sort of the
angle between these detectors so that
you know what energy that gamma came
from and you know generally where it
came from physically which is a cool
piece of a cool piece of equipment I
want to try to find pictures of one of
these actual things because I actually
haven't seen one myself I've just heard
it described physically and it seems to
make sense and the second one that we
touched upon at the very end of last
class had to do with this thing right
here does anyone remember thermionic
devices well the work function for some
materials like for cz
the work function is a little less than
an Eevee it's like 0.7 electron volts
which means when you get things up to
about 2,000 Celsius or so the
temperature of the atoms themselves
exceeds the work function and the outer
electrons just boil off so if you have
two pieces of material probably in a
vacuum and one of them's like 2000 C and
one of them is let's say room
temperature you end up with this net
flux of electrons boiling off the hot
one - the cold one and this has been one
of the methods proposed to directly
convert heat to electricity for
ultra-high temperature applications like
space reactors or other things that can
get super crazy hot so it's at one of
those energy conversion mechanisms did
anyone ever hear about this one in high
school I highly highly doubt that it
would ever be mentioned one of the
professors in our department Elias gift
topless is one of the folks that came up
with this whole idea and in my in my
freshman know in my senior design course
we actually designed a space reactor
that uses their my onyx and he showed up
in the audience by surprise and that's
probably the dumbest I've ever looked in
a presentation explaining something that
someone invented to them they knew every
single mistake and everything that was
wrong so since then I've kind of boned
up on there my onyx knowledge but that's
enough for the photon stuff now we want
to start getting into ion nuclear
interactions and in today's reading it
started off I think the first paragraph
went something like the formula for
stopping power can be expressed as
follows squared times log of B squared
over mean ionization energy and I find
this explanation to be unsatisfactory
I'm not a fan of the kind of books that
just say here's a formula for practice
plug things in and use them so instead
I'm gonna skip ahead to a little bit of
next week's reading or the yep reading
and actually derive it so a for and I
just throw up a formula like this it's
like how the hell do you remember that
right now well it's going to make a lot
more sense once we actually derive it so
let's set up this problem
you have a charged particle with charge
little Z times e little Z will say is
the number of protons in this nucleus or
the charge on an electron if you want it
times the unit charge of an electron and
it's firing at some other electrons
somewhere else in the material so the
basis of any sort of ion electron
interaction who has to start with the
ion being either struck or repelled I'm
sorry with the electron being struck or
repelled by the ion and so let's say
that this ion exists will draw kind of a
unit cylinder around this physical
situation and if we draw this distance
right here it's one of those rare cases
where this the nomenclature is the same
in pretty much every reading there's
this distance B which we call the impact
parameter it's kind of a funny name for
it but it just means by how close does
your particle get to that electron when
it undergoes this single interaction and
so this particle is moving quite fast
with some speed V towards and then away
from this electron and what's going to
happen is there's going to be some sort
of a Coulomb force between this charged
particle and this electron so let's say
you're firing an electron and an
electron there's going to be some
negative repulsion or if you're firing
an ion at an electron there might be
some positive attraction but at any rate
there's gonna be some deflection so
let's just say it's a negatively charged
particle if we draw it's actual
trajectory it's actually going to go off
kind of barely in that direction right
two charges passing in the night they
know each other's there and they kind of
repel each other so what we want to do
is figure out what is the total amount
of force and the X in the Y direction
let's just define our axes to make sure
we're all on the same page and can we
resolve that into a total amount of
energy lost per unit distance this
quantity right here which we referred to
as stopping power
before we launch into it does anyone
know why I put a negative sign on this
quantity
exactly yep if you're changing the
energy and the particle unless it's
let's say following it to some
gravitational field which we're not
covering today or ever then it's all any
sort of interaction is going to cause
the particle to lose some energy so this
quantity right here is going to be
negative and so this quantity right here
is got to be positive we stick a minus
sign in front of it but let's get back
to the basics then what is the force
between this charged particle and the
electron from 802 this Coulomb force
there's a constant just call it K not
because the reading calls it K not yep
so this is like your q1 and your q2
right you're a charged one in charge two
over the distance squared let's call
that the distance between the two
particles and so now we can say if this
is the distance away in the X direction
then we know that R is root x squared
plus B squared so we can stick that in
there and we know that our Coulomb force
would then be this K naught little ze
squared over a root I'm sorry not square
root just x squared plus B squared so
like we've done with everything so far
in the class we really it's kind of dark
in the back like we've done ever with
everything in the class let's split this
up into x and y forces so if we assume
that the electron basically doesn't move
what's the net amount of force in the X
direction that this particle is gonna
feel so when it goes from minus infinity
so over here to plus infinity like over
here zero why do you say that exactly
whatever force it feels repelling it
from here as soon as it hits this
midpoint it gets that same amount of
repulsion in the other direction so your
net force if you integrate from minus
infinity to infinity of your X force as
a function of T that comes out to zero
which makes our life a lot easier all we
have to worry about is the total
integral of the Y force to figure out
how much net deflection do we get in
that direction this integral is also
better known as a momentum anyone
recognize where this comes from if you
take the integral of a force it's like
the integral of a mass times an
acceleration which is like mass times
the integral of acceleration which is
like MV which is a momentum
this is where some of our particle wave
stuff is going to get funky because
we're gonna start throwing in
expressions for particle Momentum's in
wave equations when we start to
determine well if this is really an
electron there's some limitations on how
we can treat it or it kind of loses its
character as a particle so I just want
to warn you that that's coming up so now
let's make an expression for the Y force
if we were to say what is the Y momentum
imparted which is an integral of the Y
component of the force DT we already
have the expression for the force like
you guys derived k naught times little
ze times e over R squared which is x
squared plus V squared and then how do
we get the Y component of it
well we've got to define an angle let's
our angle theta what's the Y component
of that force
yeah it's just times cosine theta DT
what's the expression for cosine theta
in this physical situation
close be over our and in this case our
is root x squared plus B squared and the
last thing we want is because we have
things in terms of X and B B is a
constant X is a variable T's kind of the
wrong variable so we can do a variable
change and say this is equivalent to the
velocity of the particle over I'm sorry
to DX over V we're just using this whole
like velocity equals what is it distance
times time so our whole what is it yeah
Thank You distance equals velocity times
time
thanks Russia okay anyway yeah so
luckily I had the expression right in
the explanation wrong so thank you was
that Luke or Jared's voice awesome okay
so let's put this whole expression in
keep that little embarrassment behind us
we have the integral from negative to
plus infinity of K not little z e
squared times B over x squared plus B
squared times the square root of itself
so let's just say x squared plus b
squared to the three-halves and there's
a V on the bottom DX this is finally
evaluable so we're getting closer let's
take all the constants and shove them
outside the integral so we have a K not
Z squared EB over V squared B over
velocity times the integral of just 1
over x squared plus B squared to the
three-halves DX not remembering the
formula off the top of my head I yeah
yes that's that's our we'll call it a
crude derivation but if we're assuming
that the electron basically doesn't
change position that it changes so
little then we're going to assume that
also the velocity basically doesn't
change that one collision for a high
enough velocity doesn't lose that much
energy so that's that's what we're going
with for now and we'll actually be able
to compare this kind of crude derivation
to one done from quantum mechanics and
they look pretty similar there's like an
extra factor of two or something but as
I showed you guys in preparing for the
test when I said nine equals about ten
therefore follows that one equals about
two and as long as we get the constants
in orders of magnitude right we're gonna
gain the physical intuition for what
we're looking at I'll leave it up there
that's fine anyway evaluated this
integral and it came out to something
like two over B squared
so this just comes out to K naught Z
squared B with a two over two VB squared
cancel the B's I don't know where that
two came from whatever and yeah that's
what we have for the stopping power for
this sort of one particle hitting one
electron now we have the oh sorry that's
the momentum equation but we're
interested in the change in energy so
what's that equation we've used before
to go for momentum to energy our kinetic
energy T
all the way around so let's do it that
way right so P equals root 2 MT right
okay
so square both sides yeah you got it and
we have our energy T is P squared over
2m so let's take this small little mess
stick it in here and then we end up with
4 K naught squared little Z squared e to
the fourth over 2m v squared B cool and
so this gives us the little differential
energy change from one electron
collision yeah I think we cancel one of
those right oh yeah you're right thank
you
comes back B squared B squared yep
you're right thank you so now we've only
accounted for the ion hitting a single
electron as it moves through this hollow
cylinder of whatever medium it's going
through so this is when we can kind of
take things back from abstract to
reality and say alright it's moving
through some actual material and we have
to describe its electron density in this
cylindrical shell so the electron
density in the cylindrical shell depends
on well the number density of the
material itself just how many atoms are
there times big Z the number of protons
in that nucleus and therefore the number
of electrons in each nucleus and the
volume of this cylindrical shell so
what's the expression for the volume of
the cylindrical shell in differential
form yeah I started hearing I heard it -
that's correct
keep going
well two pi B gives us the circumference
of this circle on the outside of the
cylinder and if we add a little DB there
some differential thickness element and
we add on a little DX for some
differential distance down this cylinder
we end up with two pi B DB DX multiplied
by this stuff and we get some
differential change in energy scales
like let's say there's a 4 and a 2 there
so we end up with 4 that's not a 4 pi K
naught squared little Z squared big z e
to the fourth b DV DX over m v squared b
squared now those other B's cancel we
can divide everything by DX and we've
already almost got our stopping power
expression we're getting pretty close
let anyone see some similarities between
the one I just threw out of my head and
what we've got so far we've almost got
the makings of it so now if we want to
account for the fact that our charge
particle is probably not shooting
through the center of a perfect hollow
cylinder but we're just firing it into
like actual matter we have to account
for every possible impact parameter in
every possible cylindrical shell that it
would be moving through so in this case
we can integrate this we've already got
our DB right there that's our
integrating variable and now here's
where things get a little Trixie can we
actually integrate this from an impact
parameter of zero
and this is not an easy question
actually so what do you guys think so
Luke says no why
mm-hmm
we actually have an over B we have a V
squared but that's not our integrating
variable yeah so we have like a 1 over B
looking hmm yeah that's fine that's true
there's another there's another more
physical reason though but you're right
mathematically can you know precisely
the location of an electron ever now I
see a lot of people saying no why do you
say that that's right there's this thing
the debroglie uncertainty principle it's
kind of the kind of a punchline of a lot
of quantum mechanic jokes you never know
where something's gonna be or where it's
going we used to say this about some of
the older professors in this department
if you call them and say I'm on my way
I'm getting there as fast as I can they
could be anywhere in the world and if
they say don't worry I'm three miles
away you don't know how long it's gonna
take him to get here same thing with me
and getting here although I was I was on
MIT Standard Time which means five
minutes late not bad so in this case we
have to ascribe the electron some sort
of a wavelength so in this case we can't
just treat the electron like a particle
whose position we know we're gonna go
with our original equation for a photon
energy which looks like HC over lambda
rearrange that so that we'll have some
lambda wavelength equals H C over e I'm
sorry this is a momentum thing not an
energy thing
and what's the momentum of the electron
from the classical definition there's
just mass times velocity right yeah so
we'll just stick in a mass of the
electron times the velocity right there
and this wavelength right here the
debroglie wavelength of the electron is
as close as we can specify that impact
parameter and it turns out to be you
know pretty significant like on the
order of 0.1 two point two angstroms you
can't tell where an electron is gonna be
finer than that so we're going to have
this be minimum I'll just write that in
there and some be maximum where R be
minimum is the same as our de Broglie
wavelength of the electron because we
can't define its position any better
than that which is just Planck's
constant over its mass times velocity
for B max it comes out to something like
HV over this quantity I bar what's
called the mean ionization potential
what this quantity physically represents
is that if your impact parameter is too
large then the electron will or the
charge particle will feel so little
force that it won't eject an electron it
won't really be deflected and the
farthest away it can be corresponds to
the minimum amount of energy to create
an average ionization in the material
and this mean ionization potential
scales with something like this constant
K times Z where K is on the order of
like 30 to 35 I think it's like evey but
remarkably tight constant so picking a
mean value like that is no problem and
there we have our B min and B max those
are our limits of integration I think
that plan is just to fill up the boards
today so let's write out the final
integral that we have and see what we
get
so we have our stopping power should be
integral from B min H over MV to B max H
V over I bar of let's say 4 pi K naught
squared little Z squared big z e to the
fourth over MV squared B DB and like I
think Sarah it was it's our that you
mentioned that we could have a we'd have
a log I forget who's mentioned it sorry
I was Luke okay you're right so it ends
up just being a natural log it's like
all this junk on the outside times the
integral of 1 over B so this just comes
out to 4 pi K naught squared little Z
squared big z e to the fourth over MV
squared times the natural log of the B
max
over demon see the H is canceled we get
a V squared and so all this stuff inside
just becomes the natural log of MV
squared over mean ionization potential
and we've arrived basically at the same
equation that we have over there that I
took the care to memorize on the plane
so great that we've gone here through
the math let's actually see what this
means and we're gonna go into some of
the limits of validity like Luke was
saying where you can't have a natural
log of zero so the stopping power
formula isn't quite going to work at
zero nor will it work at super low
energies so if you want to write what
this should be proportional to I kind of
see some constants here that we don't
really care they don't vary at all but
this is looks kind of like a kinetic
energy term doesn't it like a kinetic
energy term so it's kind of proportional
to this function 1 over T times the
natural log of T when you get rid of all
the constants and just express it in
terms of the variables it looks a whole
lot simpler and so let's see what this
would look like if we started to graph
it out and this is pretty universal for
any charge particle stopping power so if
this was the kinetic energy T and this
was our stopping power we've got this 1
over T term that's gonna look something
like this and we have this natural log
of T term which is going to look
something like this and that actually
goes down to infinity so like Luke was
saying if these two are multiplied by
each other we're not gonna have negative
infinity as a stopping power which would
physically mean that once the particle
hits zero energy it speeds up to
infinite speed and that doesn't make any
sense but we can start to draw what the
curve would look like with this general
envelope and so at low energies the
stopping power kind of scales like 1
over E
let's now start drawing another graph
with a little more physical intuition
the range of the particle so while
stopping power might be kind of a new
quantity that represents the
differential amount of energy loss as a
function of distance that's kind of a
mouthful the range is pretty simple just
how far it goes so to get the range from
the stopping power you can integrate
let's say you fire a particle into a
bunch of matter at some energy T so you
start off at energy T and you want to
see how far it gets at distance 0 well
you can just integrate the stopping
power as a function of T or you can
switch your limits of integration let's
see I'm sorry I'm not gonna switch those
limits of integration yet which is like
saying from zero to T of DT DX DT which
is like saying from zero to T of DT DX
to the minus 1 DX much simpler
expression and when you forget all the
crazy constants and you just take this
kind of form as the red the variable
part of the expression for stopping
power for unless your energy is really
high and if natural log counts at all
your range kind of scales like the
integral of just 1 over T I'm sorry that
to the minus 1 which is like the
integral of T which is like T squared
which means that this is because you a
pretty interesting intuitive result that
the range of the particle increases with
the square of its energy so this gives
you a good hint to say if I increase the
particle by a certain amount I'll
increase the range by the square root of
that increase so anyway let's start
drawing this range curve as a function
of X what this says right here is that
if we start our particle at some high
energy right and we're firing it into
the material and it's losing energy as
it goes
and we track this value of the stopping
power to figure out how far it's going
to go let me change that in a second for
the first little while as this particle
loses more and more energy its stopping
power stays mostly constant and it loses
a pretty constant amount of energy as a
function of time as its energy gets
lower and lower it loses more and more
as a function of position what this
actually means is that as the velocity
goes down or as the particles energy
goes down it spends more time in the
vicinity of the electron and gets
deflected more it's just that kind of a
simple argument like the more time it
spends near this electron the more it
feels to push and so it will lose more
and more energy as its energy gets lower
and lower until you hit the point where
this curve breaks down where do you guys
think that is even mathematically
speaking
well what happens if your natural
long-term is negative here right then
you get a negative stopping power which
would be like the particle picks up
energy that's not quite physical at all
so in reality we know that some point
it's gonna taper off and the stopping
power at 0 should be 0 this maximum
right here occurs around 500 times the
mean ionization potential which is a
pretty low energy but what this actually
says is that when the particle is moving
really slow it's moving so slow that
once in a while it will capture one of
those electrons like if you fire in a
proton or a heavy a positively charged
heavy ion if it's moving so slow that it
can feel the pole it will just partially
neutralize and that becomes the next
mechanism of energy loss and so if we
keep following this curve once we hit
some sort of a maximum then it's gonna
lose less and less and less energy do
less and less damage and you end up with
the same curve this kind of Bragg peak
curve that we did together when we use
this RIM code did we did I go through
the stopping range of ions and matter
with you guys or did I show you this on
the screen
remember the curve of the that's a
damage events per distance or a number
of implanted ions as a function of
distance you end up with the exact same
thing that's what the SR stands for and
swim is stopping was it what's stopping
power and range or something like that
is it the stopping power and range of
ions in matter I don't know but salsa
rim is is a gigantic stopping power
database and a big Monte Carlo engine so
it takes an equation just like this one
or
yeah just like this one or that one
whichever one you want and decides full
how often is the particle going to lose
how much energy depending on where it
happens to be and that's all there is to
it
this point here we would call the range
or like the average range at which well
that's not quite right
there'd be some average range around
here where the particles actually stop
when their energy goes to zero and in
reality because every one of these
processes is random in nature the impact
parameter is going to be kind of random
not every particle will stop at the same
place because all the electrons are
moving around in the atoms so there's
going to be some sort of a a range of
ranges which we call straggling which is
to say that not all of the particles end
up at the exact same range but they end
up pretty close I think I want to pause
here for a second see if there's any
questions from this for board derivation
or any intuition questions that you guys
might have yeah oh yeah where'd that go
let's trace this through let's
oh yeah let's see ah so the change in
energy should have been a negative
change in energy so if we oh my god it
went missing there so there we go that's
the only other place it seems to be
missing okay great
cool then if you want to start looking
at the number of damage events that this
particle will incur we'll call this the
number of ion pairs which might look
suspiciously familiar if you guys
remember the Chadwick paper he was
talking about this proton of this energy
should make this many ion pairs at this
distance now you guys actually have the
tools to find out what that number
should be because it's gonna be one over
some ion pair energy usually around 30
to 35 easy depending on the material
times DT DX which is to say when the
stopping power is higher you're going to
have more ion pairs produced as a
function of distance so the real label
for this y-axis here should be like ion
pairs or damage or defects or anything
like that that refers to the same kind
of thing as damage to the material
either by ionization or even by similar
nuclear processes and so that's what
results in those rim curves that we
showed from before where you have let's
say a bunch of protons entering a
material here at some high energy they
don't lose very much energy when they go
in but as soon as they get to a low
enough energy where they're stopping
power reaches a maximum they dump most
of their energy in there and this is the
basis behind proton cancer therapy which
I mentioned to you guys on the first or
second day of class now that we know
both exponential attenuation and
stopping power we can explain
theoretically why proton therapy is a
more effective treatment so let's say
this is the person can
is a tumor say it's right there and you
have a choice between firing in an x-ray
or firing in a proton what is the dose
of this person not just to the tumor but
through the whole person going to look
like for x-rays right so if we look at
the number of ion pairs and let's say
this is the thickness of the person and
the tumor is in this range and if you
send in your x-rays or you send in your
protons what is a number of ion pairs
produced from x-ray or from proton going
to look like an either case so first of
all who wants do the x-ray one or tell
me what it'll be you guys yeah Luke it
would be fairly flat but there would be
some decay to it so let's say we define
some initial intensity x-rays just get
attenuated exponentially so you're going
to do a whole lot of damage to the
person before the x-rays reach the tumor
which is why when you do x-ray therapy
you have to send in x-rays from a bunch
of different locations so that the tumor
gets out the most and the rest of the
person and any location doesn't get that
much dose for proton therapy it's quite
different it looks just like this so you
might do a little bit of damage as you
go in and you tune the energy of those
protons so that they do all the damage
in the tumor and then they stop in the
tumor or just beyond it so that they
don't do any more damage to the rest of
the person and they do very little going
in and so that's why proton therapy
centers are popping up all over the
world because it's a more effective
treatment it's also more expensive
because you need a proton accelerator so
then here's a question for you this is
something they actually do in the lab
say here's your human there's your tumor
there's your proton gun at a fixed to
fifty MeV firing protons out how do you
change the range of those protons
without changing their energy is what
the distance an ounce of trouble
specifically I mean if it's really if
they travel in a vacuum do they lose
energy no so what can you do you could
change you could deflect them and change
their direction but as well get into on
Tuesday if you deflect them they're
going to emit lots of x-rays in the form
of bremsstrahlung so that's probably not
what we want to do you can put stuff and
I can't be any more specific than that
in between the proton beam and the
patient because if the stopping power
four to fifty MeV protons and fifty MeV
protons basically doesn't change then
you just put things in the way so let's
say this is the thickness of the person
you just put some tissue equivalent
stuff or what they'll call a phantom
so some tissue equivalent gel or water
or some other stuff to lower the proton
energy without deflecting the beam that
much so as you guys saw in the string
simulation if you track the 3d positions
of these protons as they enter into the
material they all go pretty straight and
then they start getting funny life
computer can fly the ions faster than I
can but no matter what it goes through
here while the protons have high energy
they don't get deflected much they don't
lose that much energy and you could very
finely tune the amount of stuff in the
way this would be the stuff session
before entering the person so this is
why it's so useful so let me check the
time because I haven't checked at all
the clocks broken oh it's like we have
like ten minutes so now is a good time
to stop for questions and see if you
guys have any questions from the
derivation or the sort of physical
meaning of stopping power and
yeah yes the NZ n is the number density
of atoms so if you're traveling through
some actual block of matter it depends
how many atoms are in the way so if the
stopping power the total stopping power
decreases with decreasing density like
if you have if you're going through
tungsten but it happens to be a tungsten
gas that tungsten gas will not have
nearly as much stopping power as
tungsten metal because there's just more
tungsten than the way or less I'm sorry
and the Z right here is the charge per
atom to say if you're firing electrons
into something the strength of the
Coulomb force that they'll feel or let's
say the number of electrons that they
can smack into is the same as the number
of protons in that nucleus if we're not
using ionized materials and we're
typically not firing anything into
ionized materials it's just Newton
normal neutral matter does that make
more sense cool yeah Luke
it should have been there thank you pie
and should absolutely be there so
anything else yeah Danny okay the charge
per atom is Big Z the charge on the
particle is little Z because both of
them actually matter so little Z tells
you the strength of the interaction
between the particle and each electron
Big Z tells you how many electrons are
there per atom big n tells you how many
atoms are in the way and in that way you
have a complete description of the
material curious that the mass of the
charged particle is absent from this
formula isn't it yeah the mass doesn't
matter you will certainly change the
momentum of let's say a charged particle
less but in the end it's just
non-contact Coulomb forces that
determine the energy transfer between
the electrons and there and the charged
particles slowing down in the medium so
that is a curious thing to look at but
it is intentional for the case of this
ionization or electronic stopping power
the mass does not enter into it least in
this formula there's another version
derived that's in your reading that just
they kind of plop it in front of you
that's got the mass somewhere in the
natural long term somewhere where it
really doesn't change much at all except
for really high energies so if you want
to think about like well what do I want
you to know I would want you to be able
to go through this derivation again so
that I can know you can go from a
intuitive example to an actual equation
you can use graph what that equation
should look like and talk about where it
really matters and where it breaks down
like mathematically speaking if this
natural log term is negative you're not
going to have a negative stopping power
something else has got to occur and
what's happening here is neutralization
and that's why the stopping power curve
diverges for really low energies because
sometimes electrons get captured and the
other questions on stopping power cool
this is a good place to stop for now